fans want good meaningful interconnected
trilogies but it doesn't always work out
that way for every Lord of the Rings
trilogy there is a Hobbit trilogy for
every Star Wars blesser Star Wars and
that's not even counting the plethora of
unworthy spin-offs knockoffs and ripoffs
is it any wonder then that so many
trilogy slipped through the cracks
here are a few but don't expect them all
to be masterpieces the thing john
carpenter's self-described apocalypse
trilogy intends to cause nightmares and
succeeds with a fury Carpenter's The
Thing Prince of Darkness and in the
mouth of madness are all connected
thematically and meant to be considered
together these films ask more questions
about the nature of evil than the answer
what does pure evil look like can it be
killed will we recognize it when it's
staring us in the face and most
importantly what can Alice Cooper teach
us about the devil Shaun of the Dead
Edgar Wright's three flavours Cornetto
trilogy began as an in-joke about
treating a hangover with Cornetto ice
cream but led to a series of
tangentially related genre comedies
Shaun of the Dead started it all as a
film about friendship in the face of the
apocalypse where cornettos strawberry
ice cream represented the bloody undead
Edgar Wright's feature rejected Dawn of
the deads harsh critique of society
instead opting for a simpler statement
of people good zombies bad follow-ups
hot buzz a police inspired classic Oh
blue Cornetto and the worlds in mint
green for the alien invasion tied it all
together
rewriting genre tropes of their own to
great success The Addams Family we loved
The Addams Family
most people loved The Addams Family
Values even more so how haven't we heard
about the third film sooner 1998's the
Addams family reunion is that rarest of
oddities a bad movie with Tim Curry in
it good as they are as Gomez and
Morticia in the Addams family reunion
Tim Curry and Daryl Hannah can't quite
compete with brawl Julia and Angelica
Houston the other replacements fare
worse to be fair even the original cast
would have struggled to make sense of a
plot where a disease turns the elder
atoms as normal Cruel Intentions sure
Cruel Intentions kept us entertained
Ryan Phillippe's remarkably punchable
pout
Sarah Michelle Gellar's cheeky threats
Selma blares gull
and Reese Witherspoon's ridiculous
innocence at just enough charm to this
silly misanthropic tale of almost
kissing step-siblings following the
success of the film a Cruel Intentions
TV series was shot abandoned and then
allegedly re-edited with patched in
skinemax ready adult content before
being released as a direct-to-video
prequel cruel intentions - of course
it's bad but there's more cruel
intentions 3 is basically a lower budget
cruel intentions by way of wild things -
what made each of those previous movies
sort of interesting believe it or not
it's worse shocking right Dungeons &
Dragons no one would blame you if you
missed 2000's Dungeons & Dragons film
which beat Peter Jackson's similarly
fantastic Lord of the Rings trilogy into
the theatres but was quickly obscured by
it there was one major problem with
Dungeons & Dragons the classic tabletop
game depends entirely upon players input
and the narrative skills of Dungeon
Master's for its continuing appeal you
can't just slap the DMD brand on a
generic fantasy film and lure fantasy
nerds into the theaters the first film
has all the hallmarks of a garbage 1980s
fantasy script that was dusted off and
rebranded and features Marlon Wayans as
snails that Jar Jar Binks of fantasy
realms there are two direct-to-video
sequels avoid them like the plague you
know what I've got a new neighbor dumb
rittany this is the realest thing I've
heard of Big Momma's House taking one
too many pages from the Nutty Professor
section of Eddie Murphy's career
playbook Martin Lawrence put on a fat
suit and played a horribly stereotypical
character for cheap laughs not once but
three times Big Momma's House and Big
Momma's House two are essentially
retreads of mrs. Doubtfire where the
flimsy FBI man goes undercover as an old
lady gimmick to his credit
Lawrence's Big Momma beats Tyler Perry's
Madea at her own tired game but it's
still too close to minstrelsy for our
comfort we can only hope that Big
Momma's like father like son
sealed this overwrought franchise's fate
Legally Blonde unlike its empty-headed
peers Legally Blonde roseabove a tired
premise and defied our jaded
expectations then came the sequels
Legally Blonde
2
red white and blonde retained its
principal actress and that's all
everything from the Capitol Hill setting
to Witherspoon's tone deaf getup failed
to impress fans and critics the
straight-to-video Legally Blonde reap
ashes tired blonde jokes at a prep
school setting with neither
Witherspoon's charisma nor a halfway
entertaining concept to distract us from
its cash grab e1 dimensionality this
movie ought to qualify as an act of war
we're surprised the filmmakers haven't
been sued for damages you can't get the
people to care watch me
desperado trilogies aren't cheap and
they usually require the backing of big
Hollywood studios but Robert Rodriguez's
Mexico trilogy is an exception el
Mariachi the first movie in the series
was produced for only $7,000 and was
purchased by Columbia Pictures who went
on to finance the rest of the trilogy
when the second film desperado replaced
the lead with Antonio Banderas the
series hit its high point Once Upon a
Time in Mexico the final movie in the
trilogy was famously made in just seven
weeks making it a fun experiment more
than a cohesive movie Rodriguez is DIY
sensibilities in making the Mexico
trilogy proves that awesome shoot-'em-up
action movies can be made for a fraction
of typical Hollywood budgets dark man a
trilogy in the technical sense only the
dark man series follows the established
tradition of an inverse relationship
between quality and sequel number Sam
Raimi's original dark man takes a stupid
premise and makes it pulpy and palatable
the dark man series later entries
neutered the movies by putting the
originals director in the role of
executive producer and hiring a
competent though bland director instead
to make things even less coherent part
three was originally going to be part
two and vice-versa
that's the extent of the sequels
uselessness in the franchise what order
they're viewed in doesn't even matter
[Music]
doesn't matter paint matters thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]